en la mayoría de los capacitores tenemos
un material no conductor entre las dos
placas de metal que conforman a este
capacitor y esto se hace por dos razones
una es que evita que se toquen las dos
placas de metal lo cual es importante ya
que si esas placas de metal se tocaran
entre sí entonces no se podría almacenar
la carga ya que habríamos completado el
circuito pero hay otro beneficio de
insertar un material no conductor entre
estas dos capas de metal esto siempre va
a incrementar la capacitancia del
capacitor siempre y cuando el material
sea no conductor no importa de qué
material sea siempre y cuando no
cambiemos el área o la separación entre
las placas el colocar un material no
conductor siempre va a incrementar la
capacitancia el nombre que le damos a
que el material no conductor que se
coloca entre las capas metálicas de un
capacitor es díaz eléctrico pero porque
un día eléctrico va a incrementar la
capacitancia
para descubrirlo veamos este ejemplo
conectamos una batería de voltaje ve a
un capacitor las cargas se van a separar
ahora digamos que quitamos la batería y
vemos que las cargas se quedan atascadas
en cada placa ya que las cargas
negativas no tienen una ruta para
reunirse con las cargas positivas así
que aunque quitemos la batería vamos a
mantener la misma carga así como el
voltaje que se va a mantener igual al
voltaje que tenía la batería ahora
imaginen que insertamos un día eléctrico
entre las placas metálicas de este
capacitor el material dieléctrico está
conformado por átomos y moléculas las
cuales cuando se colocan entre las
placas de este capacitor cargado las
cargas negativas en el material
dieléctrico se van a sentir atraídas
hacia las cargas positivas de la placa
del capacitor pero estas cargas
negativas no pueden llegar a estas
cargas positivas de la plata ya que este
día eléctrico no es conductor
sin embargo las cargas negativas se
pueden cambiar de lugar o alinearse
hacia la placa positiva esto ocasiona
que la carga en los átomos y moléculas
de este material dieléctrico se vuelvan
polarizadas viéndolo de otra manera
podríamos decir que el átomo se estira
de manera que un extremo se vuelve más o
menos en general negativo y el otro
extremo se vuelve en general positivo
también es posible que el material
dieléctrico ya estuviera polarizado ya
que algunas moléculas naturalmente están
polarizadas como las moléculas del agua
en este caso cuando colocamos el día
eléctrico entre las capas del capacitor
cargado la atracción entre el lado
negativo de la molécula polarizada y la
placa positiva del capacitor se van a
traer va a ocasionar que las moléculas
polarizadas noten permitiendo que los
lados negativos estén un poquito más
cercanos
placa positiva de cualquier forma el
resultado final es que el lado negativo
de los átomos y moléculas va a estar de
cara hacia la placa positiva del
capacitor cargado y los lados positivos
de los átomos y moléculas van a estar de
cara hacia la placa negativa de este
capacitor cargado y como es que esto
incrementa la capacitancia la razón de
esto es porque se reduce el voltaje
entre las placas del capacitor y reduce
el voltaje porque aunque tenemos la
misma carga en ambas placas del
capacitor de la que teníamos cuando se
cargó con la batería la contribución al
voltaje a través de las placas está
siendo parcialmente cancelada ya que
algunas de las cargas del lado positivo
del capacitor tienen su contribución al
voltaje negada por el hecho de que
tienen una carga negativa junto a ellas
de forma similar del lado negativo del
capacitor seguimos teniendo la misma
cantidad de carga que hemos tenido antes
pero
de las cargas negativas tienen
canceladas su contribución al voltaje
por el hecho de que tienen una carga
positiva junto a ellas por lo que la
carga total en este capacitor se
mantiene igual pero el voltaje a través
de las placas sea decremento debido a la
polarización del material dieléctrico si
vemos la definición de capacitancia
vemos que si la carga permanece igual
pero disminuye el voltaje la
capacitancia se va a incrementar ya que
al dividir entre un número más pequeño
por el voltaje nos va a dar un mayor
valor para la capacitancia así que en
este caso insertar un día eléctrico va a
aumentar la capacitancia al disminuir el
voltaje veamos otro caso en donde
insertamos un día eléctrico nuevamente
pongamos una batería de voltaje ve a
cargar por completo un capacitor y ahora
pongamos un día eléctrico entre las
placas de este capacitor cargado
en esta ocasión no vamos a dejar
conectada la batería que va a suceder
ahora pues igual que en el caso anterior
las moléculas y átomos de este material
se van a polarizar y se van a alinear en
estas placas se van a polarizar y se van
a alinear de manera que sus lados
negativos vean hacia la placa positiva y
en sus lados positivos vean hacia la
placa negativa lo que de nuevo va a
reducir el voltaje entre estas dos
placas pero recuerden que dejamos
conectada la batería y esta batería va a
hacer lo que toda la batería tiene que
hacer para mantener el voltaje a través
de este capacitor igual que este voltaje
sea el mismo que el voltaje de la
batería ya que esto es lo que hacen las
baterías tratan de mantener un voltaje
constante y ya que el día eléctrico
reduce el voltaje entre las placas del
capacitor al cancelar las contribuciones
de algunas de las cargas en las placas
la batería va a ocasionar que más cargas
se separen
hasta que el voltaje a través del
capacitor sea el mismo que el voltaje de
la batería por lo que las cargas
almacenadas en el capacitor van a
aumentar pero el voltaje va a permanecer
igual si vemos de nuevo la definición de
capacitancia la carga en el capacitor
aumenta después de que insertamos el día
eléctrico pero el voltaje a través de
las placas del capacitor permaneció
igual ya que sigue conectado a la misma
batería por lo que de nuevo el efecto de
insertar un eléctrico es el de aumentar
la capacitancia en este caso una mayor
cantidad de carga paga la misma cantidad
de voltaje para calcular cuánto más se
aumentó la carga necesitamos conocer lo
que se llama la constante dieléctrica
del material que insertamos entre las
dos placas la constante dieléctrica a
menudo se representa con la letra griega
capa o simplemente una caja la fórmula
para calcular cuánto cambia el día
eléctrico la capacitancia es bastante
sencilla
si la capacitancia de un capacitor antes
de insertar el día eléctrico es c
entonces la capacitancia después de
insertar el día eléctrico va a ser 14 y
debemos notar que como un día eléctrico
siempre va a aumentar la capacitancia la
constante dieléctrica k para un material
no conductor siempre va a ser mayor a un
1 si por ejemplo un capacitor tiene una
capacitancia de 4 paradas cuando
insertamos un día eléctrico con una
constante dieléctrica igual a 3 la
capacitancia será ahora de 12 fax